33 percent of high school graduates
never read another book for the rest of
their lives 42 percent of college
graduates never read another book for
the rest of their lives eighty percent
of U.S families did not buy a book or
read a book last year seventy percent of
U.S adults have not been in a bookstore
in the last five years 57 of new books
are not read to completion and I'll
admit I'm guilty of that stat as well
though all right
I did I completed more books than ever
before this year and you know what's
crazy is if you read only one book per
month that will put you in the top one
percent of income earners in our society
watch this but if you read one book per
week that will make you one of the best
educated smartest and most capable and
highest paid people in your field
regular reading will transform your life
completely